دكتورة ديبورا هارينجتون مرحبًا بك في
البرنامج، شكرًا جزيلاً لك، لقد
عدت للتو من غزة، أنت
طبيبة توليد وذهبت لعلاج النساء
والأطفال، أعتقد ما الذي رأيته هناك،
لماذا ذهبت حتى أم ذهبت لأنني
كنت كذلك  إلى غزة عدة مرات أه لقد
ذهبت منذ عام 2016 كجزء من
مجموعة تدريس لم أواجه أي
صراع من قبل ولم أتعرض لهذه
الظروف من قبل وما رأيته كان في
ألاكسا التي تقع في المنطقة الوسطى
مستشفى كان مكتظًا
بأعداد المرضى الذين نفد صبرهم،
كان مكتظًا بحالات الطوارئ آه،
حالات الصدمة تأتي طوال الوقت
بمستوى لم يتم إعداده
للتعامل معه، فأكثر ما لاحظته أه
هم النساء  الأطفال والرجال الذين يقاتلون في سن
المقاتلين لذلك أعتقد أنني كنت أتوقع
في بعض النواحي أن هذه كانت
حالة حرب وبالتالي كنت
أتوقع نوعًا ما أنه
ربما سيكون هناك شباب أم أو آه كما تعلم
آه جميع أنواع الضحايا كما تعلمون
عبر جميع أطياف المجتمع ولكن
في الواقع ما رأيته بأغلبية ساحقة
هو الأطفال وفي أحد الأيام كنت
أفكر أن هذا هو يوم رأس السنة الجديدة وكانت هناك
لحظة نظرت فيها للتو
إلى ساعتي وكانت الساعة حوالي الثانية:
بعد الظهر و  كانت لدينا إصابات جماعية
قادمة، وفي الواقع كان ذلك من
ملجأ مدرسة حيث كان هناك
قصف وانفجار، وكانت
لدينا إصابات جماعية قادمة
ونظرت حولي في غرفة الإنعاش
حيث يتم نقل جميع المرضى الأكثر مرضًا
ومن بين المرضى الخمسة في
غرفة الاستراحة، أربعة منهم
أطفال، أحدهم مصاب بإصابة
مروعة، إصابة شاتيل في
الدماغ، لم نكن لننجو أم،
ثم الأطفال الآخرون الذين يعانون من
مزيج رهيب من أم، كما تعلمون مفتوح  كسور أم بتر
جزئي جروح مفتوحة في الصدر
تمزقات مروعة من شظايا إلى
نوع من الصدر وأم والرأس
والحروق وكان ذلك كل يوم كما
تعلم عندما أنظر حول
قسم الطوارئ كان انطباعي الساحق
هو لماذا يوجد الكثير من الأطفال هنا كما
تعلمون هناك  كان هناك الكثير من الأطفال
ولماذا كان هناك الكثير من الأطفال هنا،
لا أعرف سوى القصف، فمن الواضح أننا كنا
نستقبل الضحايا من
المنطقة المحيطة بالمستشفى مباشرة
وكانوا يأتون لأن تلك
المناطق كانت مستهدفة وكانت
تتعرض للقصف بنيران القناصة  اه اه قصف وهذا ما وهذا ما
كنا
نشاهده وكما تعلم، إلى جانب
الضحايا المروعين، كان هناك
العديد من الأشخاص الذين جاءوا ميتين
وبعض المشاهد التي تعرفها
لم أتوقع رؤيتها أبدًا، أعني أنني اعتقدت أنني
كنت كذلك  لقد كنت مستعدًا جيدًا لهذا الأمر،
كنت تعلم أنني فكرت فيما
قد أراه، لكن ما
أذهلني هو أنك زرت غزة كما
قلت عدة مرات،
لم يكن النظام الصحي هناك رائعًا على الإطلاق، ولكن هناك
الكثير من المستشفيات هناك
ما هي حالة الكثير من المستشفيات الآن
لأننا نسمع أن الوضع الصحي برمته
ينهار، لذلك أعتقد أنه كان هناك
نوع من
التفكيك المنهجي لنظام الرعاية الصحية،
إنه تقريبًا مثل نوع من
السقوط حقًا، كما تعلمون أحد المستشفيات
يسقط تلو الآخر تلو الآخر
وأنظمة الرعاية الصحية يجب حماية مرافق الرعاية الصحية
فهي موجودة لأنها
موجودة من أجل الجميع أريد
تشغيل هذا الصوت B لأنه عندما تقول أنه
يجب حمايتها تحدثت إليك تعرف
شخصًا سابقًا  أنت تعرف قائدنا ميجا الذي
يعرف القليل عن الحرب وملاحقة
الإرهابيين والمدنيين هذا ما
قاله لقد شعرت أنه كان
يجب أن يظل المستشفى مفتوحًا على
وجه الخصوص ولكن جميعهم ويعالجون
المدنيين في هذه المستشفيات يسيطرون
عليهم بالرغم من ذلك  تأكد من أن الأنفاق الموجودة
أسفلهم أو أي شيء
يتم القيام به فيها غير مسموح به أه ويتم
القضاء عليه ولكن مرة أخرى يحتاجون إلى
توفير الناس دون سؤال
فهو يقول مهما كانت الحالة في الحرب
تحتاج إلى توفير الناس هل
الناس لديهم  في أي مكان يذهبون إليه، ليس لديهم أي مكان، ويقل عددهم شيئًا فشيئًا،
ما هو شعورك
كطبيب، أعني أنك محترف،
لا تؤذي أنا، أنا فقط أشعر باليأس،
أشعر أيضًا بالخجل والصدمة من ذلك
نحن نفعل هذا مع زملائي من البشر،
كما تعلمون، أنا طبيب، طوال
مسيرتي المهنية، السبب الرئيسي وراء
استيقاظي في الصباح
هو العمل في المنزل للذهاب
ومساعدة الناس.  قال الشخص الذي تحدث
معي هذا الصباح إنك تعلم أن
لديهم أشخاصًا في كل مكان يلدون في
الممرات في القاعات، وليس
لديهم موظفين لتسليمهم،
وليس لديهم القدرة في المسرح على
أداء سيزار في الأقسام  يعرفون أن الأطفال
سيتعرضون للاختناق وسيموتون
نتيجة لعدم قدرتهم على
ولادة أمهاتهم في الوقت المناسب،
وقالوا أيضًا إن وحدة حديثي الولادة الخاصة بهم مليئة
بالعدوى، إنها مليئة بالأطفال الذين يموتون بسبب
العدوى، ولا يمكنهم التعامل معها
لا توجد القدرة على التعامل معها
لأنه تم تفكيك العديد من مرافق الرعاية الصحية
دكتورة ديبورا هارينجتون
شكرًا جزيلاً لك